it's time for screen junkies bubi bites
a little William Hung 30 seconds and
then you get damn glad to be here movie
fights you just heard me quoting Ricky
Martin and William Hamish bangs we are
way off the rails but let me ask you a
question where the F my towels at who
first of all is in the house
hashtag owl nation we got an awesome
fight we're gonna talk about some
exciting stuff that's dropping this
weekend and we got some great questions
and some great fighters let's meet the
combatants first he is the longest
reigning holder of the bathroom key for
screen junkies you know from the real
rejects and he's just a quite a
formidable combatant here Greg Alba
welcome back buddy
thank you how you know I haven't missed
an episode of movie fight since you
started hosting I still don't know what
the hell a lil nation is let me tell you
what is our nation it's whatever you
want it to
like that welcome all are welcome there
you go that's thanks I appreciate that
I'm happy to be here back with Sasha on
this table oh yeah rematch that's gonna
be fun yeah Sasha I want to welcome from
her podcast everything's coming up
Simpsons breaking down how many seasons
of The Simpsons we are approaching 30 -
we don't do every episode though and
we'll probably end before the Simpsons
everything will end before the Simpsons
does it'll be running in perpetuity what
when when the earth is in flames
Julia Prescott welcome back to the party
I want to say hi to all the people in
Prescott nation that's the nation that I
share with I believe there's a football
player so last name is Prescott sounds
like a little bit of a rogue nation but
Julia welcome to you and all members of
Prescott nation thank you for being here
and last but not least I was just
enjoying I was hanging out watching TV I
put on FX Captain America winter
soldiers was on one of my top three
favorite Marvel films and it was FX
movie download so it's like I was
watching with Sasha forever hi guys
great down your back where this isn't
gonna be Prescott nation or owl nation
this is sausage perv Craver nation you
know what that's all about it so give me
that title this is a regular United
Nations of weird crap this is a great
collection of fighters I'm very excited
for this and making sense of the
festivities myself and the damn camera
whoa
Oh three bells over here I don't know
why there are three bells but there I
just walked in there were three bells
each other yeah that's how best
reproduced dan you're gonna be holding
it down in the fact zone today
excellent excellent and good luck
choosing a bell for the speed round
I don't know right I feel like it's like
the shell game around here Dan's
cosplaying as the opening title sequence
of Downton Abbey today so that's very
the only thing that happens in Downton
Abbey and it's a hit show anyway I
bought Matthew died Matthew died sorry
it's been off for years and we have just
a wonderful ray of sunshine who will be
the voice of the people as per huge Miz
Daniel Radford thank you and so for
those of you who do not know how this
works in case there is a tie or you know
we just need a deciding vote that will
be up to y'all there are lots of really
fun polls on the Twitter but the one
that counts is the one that is on
YouTube if you have any questions about
how that works click on description
below ask someone in the chat any of the
mods would be happy to help you through
that also in addition if you go to the
Twitter hashtag movie fights live you
guys always come up with wonderful
answers dank memes as you all know other
great things and so if you go in there
and you're tweeting and I like what I
see I might go ahead and shut you out on
the show which would be really funny
heck yes Danielle thank you for breaking
that down and again we have three
fighters the first one of them to
achieve four points will be our winner
the top two combatants after the first
three rounds will head on into the speed
round where it's anybody's game you can
be down big going into the speed round
and make a furious comeback
[Applause]
that horrible speedrun where I actually
disparage my beloved franchise I had to
the ride mm-hmm
brag nicely done fast furious Universal
Studios maybe you can make up for that
today we shall see let's embark on this
journey jte please drop that sick ass
package
[Music]
Thank You Thor okay so I'm pretty
excited I have not seen it yet Jordan
peels us hit theaters this weekend so we
asked you since Jordan peel has
established himself as a master of her
what classic horror film would you most
want to see Jordan Peele remake what
classic horror film you want to see
Jordan Peele remake and we'll start with
player number one Greg yeah when it
comes to this question I factored in the
strengths that Jordan Peele has
demonstrated with his films that he's
directed and he clearly excels at
psychological horror films with social
commentary infused you know Julia's got
this stare like this like really really
strong stare okay so usually he excels
at psychological horror films with
social commentary infused usually with
an african-american focus which I
remember him saying that's the kind of
genre he wishes to focus on and for what
I hear about us so many people come back
reporting the film has all those
elements and even England's a Twilight
Zone or black mare horror genre spliced
with sci-fi in there so I thought what
horror movie could Jordan Peele not only
remake but definitely improve upon the
answer for me was tales from the hood
tales from the hood is a 90s horror
anthology movie it's about a funeral
director who tells four strange tales of
horror with an african-american focus to
three drug dealers he traps in his place
of business and it's a film with
multiple stories that covers police
brutality with a zombie twist domestic
violence with a voodoo twist racism in a
political campaign with a poltergeist
hingle and gang violence with a prison
exploitation angle and usually with
remakes we always ask the question of
why we tend to remake movies that are
already great movies that deserve
remakes or ones that had great potential
but didn't quite hit it with its
execution and even though this film has
generated a cult following it's not
certified fresh' among critics and the
audience score is fresh but it's not
glowing so it's a film that has great
concepts of his execution could be a lot
sharper all around Jordan Puyol has
proven he can bled horror and comedy
seamlessly and he can
prove upon this all into their alright
by the way all three of you are fresh
and glowing I am suggesting that Jordan
PL remake the shining the salmon
Kubrick's classic now I know that a lot
of people are very precious with this
because it is a masterpiece but I also
want to point out that you know reboots
can get you know really exciting if it's
a franchise or if it's you know a movie
that we are all very familiar with and
very excited about and I think that
Jordan Peele much in the way that you
were pointing out you know gives his own
social commentary through his horror and
his suspense I think that he could add
you know an extra element to that movie
that we haven't seen before and I also
think that as we've seen with get out
then he plays really well with very
simple setups very simple environments
and sort of you know trippin on like the
psychological suspense of slowly going
mad I think that that's something that's
going to really excite audiences and I
just think that y'all's others
suggestions are bad I looked at the
trailers like no Sasha so I am going
literally classic I'm going with 1960s
eyes without a face and if you aren't
familiar with this movie which I am
assuming most people are not I'm gonna
give you a little bit of background so
it's about a woman who is horribly
disfigured in a car accident that her
father who's a surgeon basically feels
responsible for so he starts doing what
all good parents would do he starts
kidnapping other women who sort of look
like his daughter and cutting their
faces off and trying to transplant them
on to his child so that she can like go
off and have a normal life lol like
that's gonna happen
it's very dark it's very twisted she
doesn't have a mouth so all you see are
these like gaping eyes sort of looking
out at you actually writing me a little
bit of Lupita who I think is gonna get
an Oscar nomination I have seen us and
it's crazy and she is so good in it and
oh my god Winston but that's not the
point the point of this story is this
yes you're talking about like the
bizarre sci-fi elements that he's drawn
to like with Twilight Zone this movie
has that you're talking about the social
commentary we saw and get out this movie
has that and also has the gory elements
from us because at the time censors
wouldn't let the director go as far as
they wanted to with actually like taking
the faces off and no this is not like a
Travolta Cage situation although there
is a really awesome dam and the dam came
real quick and what they were doing I
think Jordan Peele is actually really
great at investigating which is the true
sense of self actually what happens when
you are inside your own skin the
discomfort in that the inability to
really have your own reflection
reflected back that's all of what us is
about like who is the true self and
that's what this movie is about it also
features one of the coolest endings
which I think Game of Thrones stole
where the father is Maul to death
spoiler alert by dogs dogs that have
been like these foreboding guardians of
this girl the whole time and they're
barking howls throughout this movie I
keep thinking about what he would do
with a score to create something that
would go along with those howls the same
way like the music in us is so important
the music and get out is so important
this movie talks about what it is to be
your true self this movie deals with
like all the stuff that you have to deal
with in family and it's exactly that
same thing of a very simple set of all
you really see is a father who loves his
child helping her in all the wrong ways
and I think that that is a story Jordan
Peele could tell incredibly well
all right Sasha coming in with eyes
without a face
[Music]
let's start with Julia because I really
have to understand why you think anybody
should touch the shining well I think
that we're talking about reboots and
we're talking about Jordan Peele who so
far has established himself as like a
really great director with original
stories right so if he's going to do a
reboot then I think it's going to be a
big reboot and eyes without a face like
you made a really compelling case like
I've never seen that movie before and it
sounds really awesome but you also I
think kind of argued your way out of
winning because you're comparing it too
much to us it sounds too similar to us
if I was you know a movie goer seeing
that trailer I'd be like well I just saw
us well so what a bad pitch but you just
argued yourself out of your thing cuz
you said he's great with original
storytelling and the shining is not just
a reboot it's also based on listen
question that were debating right now is
one see coin well the question we're
debating right now is if he had to
reboot anything that I think that he
would go big or go home I think that a
movie that The Criterion Collection
called what does it say what The
Criterion Collection call it Oh a
brilliant what is it in the film history
for its own mix of ghastly and lyrical
it was a major influence on the genre in
the decades that follow the images here
of terror of gore band explicable Beauty
are ones that have never been forgotten
and I think that that is going big on
the other hand why would he do Candyman
and details from the hood why it's not
directing Candyman doesn't matter he's
involved in a who's producing it's under
among people I think looks like the same
thing no it's not it's a horror
anthology and with Twilight Zone he's
producing that he's the face of it he's
a creative producer involved in it do a
Twilight Zone version of tales from the
hood that's essentially one of the tales
from the hood his reboot would be it is
a classic horror movie they qualify for
this question so I think it's just fine
you see I think with with your guys know
like Thanksgiving in my divorced parents
house
sorry it's just sad to say it's like I'm
getting a lot of triggers I had therapy
yesterday tomorrow shining and eyes
without a face those movies are already
great movies those don't need to be
remade tales from the hood is the one
movie out of this whole panel that had
the potential it is the only one here
that doesn't have a certified fresh'
Rotten Tomatoes score but a decent
audience score do you think it's a
little on the nose and you may not know
what do you mean my on the nose I don't
know I I looked at the trailer I must
admit that I did not I've not seen tails
from the hood but I looked at the
trailer and it seemed a little bit more
comedic Lee leaning then [ __ ] early age
that's why that's why I remake would
make it differently you're taking Keanu
and you're taking Candyman and you're
turning it into tales from the hood and
is not true it is not true you want
something that deserves to be remade
right because the point of doing a
remake is to find a wide audience again
eyes without a face is an incredible
film and I how many people in this room
have seen eyes without a face Dan
Morrill have you seen eyes without a
face no one has seen eyes no longer
exist that's a kind of film it's a
completely different argument we had
film struck for a while and we still
didn't watch eyes without a face so I
think that it says the reason my movie
it's best for what Jordan Peele has
stated he wants to do he wants to do
movies that focus on psychological
social commentary
get out has a sci-fi element infused and
I'm hearing us has a little bit more of
that and I think this would be a great
transitional step for him because this
has more supernatural elements involved
in it this is more along the lines of
what he actually wants to work on true
because on the monkey paw website they
say their mission steven is they want
artistic thought-provoking projects
groundbreaking storytelling kudos we've
visionary world building is one long
production comes in Jordan's production
social issues
tales from the road is considered an
something that was sort of envy there
was a period of time where like in the
90s
don't drink your juice while being a boy
in the hood look movies like that
started coming out but it's not
something that sir
anyway I think that's lowbrow it's very
low price equals a mouse you do
something that why can't you do eyes
without a face and have the PD Nyong'o
plays like a better common bird movie
that version why do we need another one
with Jordan Peele doing nothing they are
shooting the sequel to The Shining dr.
sleep and that's coming out and this
good that's exactly we don't need a
shiny sure we don't need a six-hour
remake of The Shining made-for-tv that
was terrible okay let's shift gears and
move to our final thoughts Greg yeah I
think Jordan Peele is clearly drawn to
films that have a surreal element but
are grounded in realistic situations and
people tales from the hood is the
perfect vehicle for him to really reach
into the bazaar and do what he does best
but even more take that symbolism to a
more overt degree we've had some
wonderful horror anthology films in the
past Creepshow was wonderful but then
there was another horror anthology films
that are met with high acclaim but don't
really get that box-office acclaim at
first they always get a cult following
you slapped Jordan peels name on it
people will tune in for it that's why I
Twilight Zone we're all very excited for
it
this movie is right up his alley and he
can improve upon something that was only
fun and entertaining into something that
is truly horrifying and effective
dealing with anthology tales an
african-american focus exploring police
brutality domestic violence gang
violence and incarceration racism and
politics all being infused with
individual supernatural twist for every
story allowing for a different sub-genre
if you were to announce this remake
there is only one director who could do
it and that's Jordan Peele The Shining
is an already amazing film that had a
six hour remake and is having a
follow-up they're beating that to death
eyes without a face as a great film it
was very effective for its time this is
effective and eerie as it once was
already those don't need to be remade
your films don't need a remake and if
you were to remake those films I don't
think peel is the right pick for it your
films already have a lot of acclaim this
one can actually use an improvement and
my pick sorts my picks suits Jordan
Peele the best this is the only movie
that could be heavily improved upon and
the fact remains the social commentary
try exploring in the 90s it's still
relevant in the
african-american community today showing
it lends itself to a modern-day reboot
black issues are more at the forefront
than in the 90s so this one just makes
the most sense for a director who's very
vocal about being passionate about these
kind of stories Thank You Sasha Julia
damn well I think I've already
established myself as being in the back
of this race but I'm gonna take a stab
anyway so yes why does the shiny need to
be remade that is a big question that I
think I started to address at the
beginning I think that if there is going
to be any reboot that's going to be a
Jordan Peele reboot again go big or go
home and I think that he could add a lot
to you know the different conspiracy
theories that have sort of swirled
around the shining since its first
released I don't know if you guys have
seen the documentary of room 237 but I
think about it a lot I think that it's
like a perfect example of you know
artist creation versus audience
reception I think that there could be
some fun with Jordan peels on personal
reception of the shining and you know
how he kind of plays with the psychology
of you know being slowly going into
madness the psychology and the social
commentary of like what it's like to be
a man was it like to you know be this
family unit was it like to you know who
is the us who's who like the person that
I'm watching my words today and I just
think that it would be really really
interesting I think that I spent out of
face again like it sounds like a badass
movie but I feel like that as a reboot
yeah is it too far in the past for it to
be an effective reboot I think we all
learned a thing or two about Murder on
the Orient Express that we don't need a
reboot of things long-forgotten and and
that's all that's all I got all right
thanks Julia
Sacha Pro raver um I think that
something that has may be forgotten by
some but still revered by others is
exactly where Jordan Hill should take
the next step I think that for him to do
tales from the hood would be a step
backward and I think that Greg you're
basically saying because he's a black
director he can only direct a film like
that and the truth is is to have him
take something that was a French cutting
edge film at the time and create
something that is so so tangible like
we're talking about the things that he
makes so eerie and frightening are
things that we recognize meeting the
parents for the first time going on a
summer vacation
to feel like you are trapped in your own
home and the person you trust the most
is the person who can hurt you the most
those are things that I think everybody
can relate to that is a universality
that Jordan Peele would absolutely crush
in making a film and when we are most
frightened it's because we see ourselves
reflected and I think that that is his
greatest power I don't think we need a
story that takes place in the hood to
understand that we are being reflected
or that a story has social commentary I
think having a story about a woman who
has no voice is actually extremely
socially relevant right now and I would
love to see what Jordan Peele could do
with that and on top of it all to have a
film that could ignite passion for this
filmmaker and for the genre in a new way
I am all for and that's why it's the
best choice for him ding ding all right
that is our round one let's head over to
the fact zone with Dan Murrow the
minister of facts here at the kids table
like sealing dinner this is very opinion
based round here I will say that
recently Jordan Peele had a bit of a
social media moment when he dressed up
as basically wearing clothing from the
shining for a nice day for people were
noting that and as social media does
immediately speculating is that he's
dropping a clue for his next movie
that's how Twitter works mm-hmm
let me ask you one fact you what's the
name of that film that sauce the full
name don't drink your juice in
south-central wait don't be a menace to
society don't be a menace to South
Central while drinking your juice in the
hood thank you all right thank you thank
you I mean that that film wins the award
for most references yeah yeah sending up
John Rowe 90s film so thank you Dan
yes yeah this was I thought these were a
lot of great choices Julie I felt like
you kind of pulled the ripcord a little
bit at the end especially
as you started as you started making
your argument you're like well at the
back of this race Amen so strong and I'm
sorry to be myself and say that I don't
think Jordan Peele should reboot
anything please please please the time
for making our arguments it's over
so yeah I appreciate where you're coming
from I I thought that take on the
shining could be good but yes so it came
down to Sasha and Greg for me and I I
think Greg made some great arguments my
thought they started to chip away your
armor a little bit and just saying it is
a Julia and Sasha set it in different
ways it does feel a little bit on the
nose that it is that it has to be this
particular set of stories and I feel
like you know he like he could tell any
story you know a story that is rooted in
in black culture or about people of
color or story that is just tangentially
or whatever so the argument I got most
excited about was Sasha's just the story
to a Jordan peels point of view and yeah
that gets my vote Dan this is also
between Sasha and Greg from me sorry
Julia but I don't I I am a somewhat of
an advocate for the ABC remake of this
shining while it is not perfect I don't
think it's horrible but that's just me I
was just saying movie fights things I'm
actually very torn because I was I was
also somewhat swayed by the concept of
maybe you're putting Jordan Peele into
too much of a box and saying you know
but Greg also brought up that you know
it's also in the wheelhouse that he
toured appeal said these are certain
kinds of stories that I want to tell and
it
could I'm almost swayed by the by the by
the the sort of narrow focused argument
but I think ultimately because Greg
brought up the fact that Jordan Peele
has addressed in the past like there's a
certain type of the thing that I'm
interested in telling right now that
that chips away that enough just for me
for me to go with Greg but it's very
it's very close I thought Sasha and Greg
both had very strong arguments all right
we're locked up at one one Danielle
what's the poll of to say it's gonna be
heard um as of right now we have 60%
tales from the hood Wow
26% four eyes without a face and 13% for
the shining other things that were
mentioned people under the stairs which
I haven't seen it forever people
understand Blacula that's just really
wanted Wicker Man and I know yes that's
Kate over and over and over voting what
role in the remake no troll - I didn't
see any troll - all right tales from the
hood up to no good
Greg one two nil to nil Julia and Sasha
looking to get on the board here is
question number two harmony currents the
beach bum is now playing what's the best
movie featuring Matthew McConaughey best
movie featuring Matthew McConaughey
Michael questions alright let's let's
return to the Meccano sense and we'll
start with Julia who I'm so glad that
we're starting with me I picked
kupo into two strings baby Oh let me
tell you about it because maybe you
forgot it is the fourth film by the
production studio or animation studio
Laika the same studio that brought us
Coraline of course and ParaNorman and
mathema conahey plays this beetle
character who's like this great samurai
and I watched a lot of videos of him in
the booth recording and he was like
super stoked to be this like goof
while action-hero guy he did it for his
kids but I also think that apart from
McConaughey's enjoyment of being in this
film that I think that it is a great
technical achievement that also has a
really strong story and was overlooked
when it or initially came to theaters
but deserves all of the awards and all
of the clout today so that's all I can
say thanks Julia yeah Sasha what you got
all right I have a film that Quentin
Tarantino listed as the tenth best film
of all time in a sight and sound poll
alongside taxi driver and the good bad
and ugly I have a film whose soundtrack
went double platinum I have a film that
gave us multiple catchphrases all
uttered by the one the only mr. Matthew
McConaughey and that film is the film
that got him discovered that is Dazed
and Confused Dazed and Confused one of
the best films of all time let me tell
you a personal story I'm in like 11th
grade smoking weed in the back of a
movie theater in Oakland California
watching Daisy confused like every day
after school because it's one of the
best movies ever what about the best
Matthew McConaughey we're talking about
the best movie Dazed and Confused gets
better with age
Danny confused it's always fantastic
tasting confused what are sick it's what
we got all right all right all right
it's where we got just keep living L IV
I am living it's what gave us that's
what I love about these high school
girls they get older I stay the same age
come on it's so fun and not only that
you know who else is in that movie Ben
Affleck Joey Lauren Adams and Renee
Zellweger Posey Parker Posey
Jovovich Berg Micky Kat Cole Hauser
Jason London Rory Cochrane it launched
so many people's careers it is in my
opinion the best Richard Linklater film
it is also the best at Matthew
McConaughey film I love Dazed and
Confused I got it I love the movie but
two of those people you name them like
who dad
electioneer on this around the corner
Graig around the horn - Greg yeah I saw
this movie actually only a couple months
ago that the one that I picked and it
drastically moved me I it was one of
those movies that after watching it I
started doing research to find out the
truth behind it because it's based on a
true story and that's Dallas buyers club
and the movie if you guys haven't seen I
feel like most one you didn't describe
the plot of this with that help or and
is it not necessary for this one up to
you
well now it's basically about a guy in
1985 in Texas an electrician and a
hustler named Ron Woodroof he was
diagnosed with AIDS told he had 30 days
to live and he ended up finding an
alternative via a legal way to keep on
living and he eventually works around he
is around the system to help AIDS
patients get the medication they need
after they're diagnosed this film was
nominated for several awards that
includes Best Picture Best Screenplay
best editing it won three Oscars for
Best Actor Best Supporting Actor and
Best Makeup and Adam I feel like out of
this panel out of all the performances
here I feel like this is Matthew
McConaughey's best performance out of
the movies I feel like this one is the
most powerful one out of the three on
this panel right now this character in
this movie is a rather unlikable
character but he earns truly
compassionate moments there's no like
save the cat moment with this character
and the writing of this film is insanely
authentic the structure of the
screenplay
and the editing spans so much time yet
in most biopics that feels over
convoluted that feels like they're doing
too much but this movie does it in such
a well-paced version and the themes that
deals with a fear rage lust addiction
the drive to keep on living overcoming
crazy obstacles of facing death topics
of homophobia I just feel like there's
so much nuance and power in this film
and it's a lot of darkness yet I feel
like it bounces it out with a lot of
heart and a lot of like really
surprisingly earned laughs in the movie
as well so if to me it's just a very
moving picture alright fight it out
the only movie on this panel that made
me cry was people on the two strings
that movie is brilliant I love that
movie if you would not sing good when
the two strings you must
like is just the best and that film is
you so realtor David like a movie it
might be just have any conversations
club too but when we're talking about
like the best film and it's not starring
Matthew McConaughey it's just featuring
Matthew McConaughey sure I feel like the
movie cuz I would have gone with the
time to kill if it was the best movie
starring Matthew McConaughey it's not
about his performance it's he's great
across the board but I feel like the
movie you're not throwing on Dallas
buyers club on a Saturday with your
friends that was gonna be my flame
except on Jay Z views and watch it and
have the best time you want to talk
about authentic the kids performances in
those movies Matthew McConaughey hadn't
done he's done one other movie before
that but this was like a big break for
through him a lot of it was improvised
his entire li VI end speech on the
football field that was based on the
conversation hit a link later had about
him and his dad that's authenticity to
me I love Dallas buyers club I think
it's the Oscar choice but we're actually
talking best I think the answer it's
awesome you pretty much stole my
argument away from you about that Dallas
buyers club I was gonna say that you
found it yourself by saying that you
would only just recently seen it because
I don't think that it's a movie that
while at the time we see it and it's
definitely like an Oscar baby movie
that's like part of the race where it
has like all the Oscar buzz words of
like a guy dying like the AIDS epidemic
like Jared Leto that's another buzzword
ring those bells Dan you know like
everything but I don't think that it's
one of those movies where we it'll stand
the test of time I don't think that
we're going to Revere it I don't think
that it's going to get a criterion
collection if any I think that it's
going to be one of those not like that's
a barometer for the best movies of all
time but I don't I think that is going
to be one of those where we're like oh
yeah I can see that when they came out
and yeah I did cry in the theater but
like I don't really remember it often
and I don't think that it's going to be
the biggest stand-up for Matthew
McConaughey's career and I think that
you've seen it so recently that you
haven't really been able to give it the
test of repeat viewings and I think that
that speaks to you know uh the films
that we're talking about today coupon
the two-streams I did say earlier that I
don't think that it
you know was seen by many people when it
first came out and it was given what it
deserved but I think that different to
Dallas buyers club that people are going
to rediscover Kubo in the - screams -
strings excuse me and like really marvel
at that specific kind of animation which
is thinking hard you guys like it's so
hard what they do the technical
achievement of like and the fact that
they are producing Pixar level or
they're neck-and-neck with Pixar of
those stories that are pulling at the
heartstrings are always about a family
they're always about this protagonist
that you know it's down on their luck
but I think that what makes Kubo stand
out is that it's a Japanese story so
it's trying to bring you know this other
kind of diverse element to it but then
also they go edgier than Pixar and the
fact that within like the first five
minutes of this film
our main character gets his eye gouged
out and then has to like save his mom
who's like you know lethargic and dying
and like all of this pressure is on his
shoulders and yet we don't feel like
that is really gratuitous and trying to
like I don't know it'd be pulling out
our heartstrings in a way that isn't
earned so I feel like that is going to
be the thing that stands the test of
time and then of course Dazed and
Confused is a great movie and I probably
would have picked it if you hadn't
already but I don't think that some of
the you know gender dynamics and some of
the commentary regarding sex age as well
so I feel like it kind of has what's
kind of some of the John Hughes movies
are kind of going through right now
where there's elements of that that feel
very misogynistic I feel like there's
elements of it that kind of glorify
bullying and I feel like it's a fun
movie it's a fun movie glorifies
bullying when all the kids are getting
spanked with the paddles it was of the
time
grandparents and say when they
defendants are all damaged and with also
with Kubo and the two strings you were
talking about you know talk cover in
Japan and having diversity when it's a
movie with in Japan but majority of the
cast are like white voice actors in that
movie and to me that really takes me out
of it I'm I did my DNA test results
recently I'm 70% Asian so I take slight
offense to that that it's primarily a
white cast in there think about really
quick the seaweed coupon the two strings
I feel like with that movie we all
talked about the greatness of the
animation but I feel like the plot
itself is rather generic I feel like
that it's a really by the numbers thing
and I think with a dazed and confused
yeah it's fun they get high haha I like
getting high too but it's just a fun
movie but with Dallas buyers club this
is the most nuanced of them all and it
has the most it's an important film I
think you want about Dallas buyers club
to say yes wells near like start crying
and start crying here a gun
giulia roll this right into your final
thoughts I just want to say I have to
bring up the jared leto thing again
because i think that that is a glaring
thing that you cannot just skip over
when you're talking about Dallas buyers
club if you're talking if you're gonna
come at me and say that not enough Asian
actors yeah right
not enough Asian actors voiced in Cuban
on two screens Jared Leto is not a
transgendered person and playing a
transgendered person on such a big stage
that they there was a whole petition
after this movie came out that they
didn't even open up the auditions or
focus on it so I just want to say Cooper
the cheese strings rules is that your
final final I just want to say that Lika
is a company that is doing the Lord's
work it is their produced out of
Portland they're not produced out of LA
in a lot of ways they feel like an indie
studio and in a lot of ways that that's
true because you know even though as I
said earlier they're pretty much neck
and neck as far as quality and you know
with story and with execution as Pixar
they're the little guy compared to Pixar
so I feel like you know we need to go
see movies like this so that this kind
of animation is still produced because
it's just not happening at all 2d
animation isn't happening stop action
animation isn't happening and that's
gonna go away and in the ways that you
know a lot of the other kind of stories
that we love to see in TV and movies are
gonna go away we need to support it so
that those kind of artists who have a
very specific trait can continue to do
their work and transfix audiences the
world around you guys oh thank you yeah
yeah Sasha so here's the thing I love
Laika and I totally agree with
absolutely everything you said and I
think the Dallas buyers club is a good
if schmaltzy movie the thing is is
somebody totally could have voiced that
character and it didn't have to be
Matthew McConaughey and so he totally
could have played Ron Wood were for
whatever his name was and it didn't have
to be Matthew McConaughey no one else
could have played Watterson then Matthew
McConaughey and that's because he was
playing him self he played himself with
a mustache and a different pair of jeans
he did something that made us all fall
in love with him that was his star
making turn and it was truly Matthew
McConaughey at his Matthew McConaughey
issed
and this is how good it is this is how
iconic it is
so iconic that jte can you throw up the
picture that I took when I walked into
the studio screen junkies that's how
good it is hey man can you replace the
drinking joke with the new can be a lot
cooler if you did that's iconography to
be clear we're not talking about Matthew
McConaughey's performance we're talking
about the movie right no it's the best
movie featuring Oh Cathy what God Hank I
cop Nick and de-stink used is just a
damn classic and I guarantee in 10 years
you'll still be watching dazing fuse
will not so be watching Dallas buyers
club Thank You Sasha Greg final thoughts
yeah I think Jason confused like I said
it's the oldest one of these three so it
has a better chance of being the more
iconic one of them all and I think it's
a fun movie it's entertaining but it
doesn't really have much it's not much
that goes on it I feel like it's a
STONER version of American Graffiti I
think American Graffiti is a better
movie that I don't mean that yeah and I
do think I really do you think when I
look back on it it glorifies bullying
it's very misogynistic I think Kubo in
the two strings while it's a great
animated movie it's varied by the
numbers and I watch the movie Coco and
I'm like they're kind of similar and I
prefer Coco over it Dallas buyers club
there's a reason that out of any of the
films here it was the only one nominated
for Best Picture you can't I don't I
really don't think saying that you can't
just say Matthew McConaughey play that
role he won the Oscar for that
performance in the movie Suicide Squad
has an Oscar okay
again it's he won the Oscar for it and
it was nominated for everything up for
Best Picture Best Screenplay best
editing for reason because the whole the
movie as a whole is great no you can't
looks like you just be if it was only
Matthew McConaughey's performance that
was good in the movie only he would have
gotten nominated but the reason all
these other nominations happened is
because the movie is a very powerful
film your films are light-hearted and
fine and maybe more rewatchable I'll
give you that but I think when I'm
thinking about the best movie I'm
thinking about the one that will really
stick with you and move you in a way
that you can that feels important
and I actually kind of teach you
something about life it's a dark heavy
drama but it's surprisingly balanced
with a lot of tender heart and just the
right amount of humor and I feel like
with Dazed and Confused I could watch a
lot of coming-of-age movies that make me
feel the same way
Kubo and the two strings same thing I
could watch a lot of animated movies
that have the same kind of messages I
haven't seen a movie like Dallas buyers
club it's honest it's haunting it's
moving it sticks with you and not only
do you go on an emotional journey but
you learned quite a bit along the way
and last thing I in my my films the only
one that actually won Oscars and stuff
so yeah Oscars my dad what's going on in
the fact zone and then please give us
your thoughts on this question that much
said from the fact zone other movies in
Quinn Santino's top ten included William
Friedkin sorcerer The Bad News Bears and
Carrie yeah he had a weird list my
thoughts I thought it was I thought it
was a close fight honestly of what put
me over was Greg's final thoughts but
not for Greg I feel like so much of the
final thoughts were tied into like well
it's the best because it won this and
it's the best because of Oscars and it's
the best because I've got more words and
I felt like that to focus so much of
your final argument on just that element
and just being like this proves that
it's the best I found myself more swayed
to Julia or Sasha because they actually
went into the film a little bit more
beyond just like prestige etcetera
that's one element so it's between
Julianne Sasha for me and I really loved
Julia's passion for the the art of Kubo
but I felt like it was more for Lika and
that and that medium and I felt like
Sasha's made a lot of points with Dazed
and Confused the fact that it leveraged
his personality it is a movie that
people remember I know I don't think
it's a classic just cuz it's old I think
it's it has resonated with people so
lots of different balance things for me
to think about but ultimately up with
Sasha and Daisy I'm pretty much in
lockstep with you here I think Dallas
buyers club is a great film I think Greg
made a strong case but
but then they they took some shots at
about how it doesn't it doesn't quite
hold up afterwards and there's certain
things you can pick apart about it so
and I didn't feel like we really hit
back with that Sasha I felt like had the
most passion about her it's great great
great Linkletter
it's got a great soundtrack there's a
lot of elements going Julia you just
make me want to donate my time and
efforts to animation but Sasha I go with
you so she gets the point like is the
bad also say that I'm married to an
animator no no he works in other stuff
but I know what the polls say okay
coming in at 38% it was Kubo in the two
streams confused 29% for Dallas buyers
club some other suggestions a time to
kill interstellar Magic Mike and
inexplicably tiptoes I know if you're
not familiar with tiptoes Google tiptoes
and yeah yeah I got a big argue with
myself around the Magic Mike things I
know it's such a it's it's really a
Channing Tatum movie I had a hard time
with this because I have not seen her
guys confused by the way I'd say the
best thing Matthew McConaughey has ever
touched is true detective but that's
just me
okay question three we are tied 1-1
Julia looking to get on the board here
we go
according to franchise producer Lorenzo
di Bonaventura transformers can you do
that again
according to franchise producer Lorenzo
di Bonaventura transformers may begin
having sexual relationships and upcoming
movies what what in the world good day
be alive oh my god so yeah these robots
are gonna be Bonin so we want to know
I'm gonna start watching though which
two robots which two robots should have
sex in a movie which of any robots which
two robots should get it on and we're
gonna start with player number three
Sasha
sausage Kirk raver I was thinking about
the Transformers movie where you do see
the the balls there is a Transformers
balls reference already so I said way
longer than anybody should considering
this question and what I came up with
was I would like to see our beloved
c-3po finally bone down with Ava from El
ex machina I think that they deserve
each other I mean Ava is somebody who
has been abused she was locked away for
her entire life she was forbidden to see
any color outside of her black and white
room she was controlled she was given so
little freedom and her sexual power was
her one way of getting freedom getting
out she had to use it to lock Kaleb in
that room and run away and now all she
needs is a good man now who's a good man
a good man is somebody who understands
human-cyborg relations
somebody who perhaps has had a little
bit too much excitement for his own
liking
but who is designed as a protocol droid
you know protocol droids do what I do
they want to please that's right he
understands etiquette he understands
customs
fluent in over six million forms of
communication you want to tell me that
sexual healing isn't one of them no sir
I know it's in there we have here two
broken souls who are just looking for a
little tenderness in this cold cold
world and I believe that they're meant
for each other all right Sasha come in
with c3 we're gonna do monitor Greg go
around the horn too Greg okay Sasha I
intentionally shorten my opening and
closing for Dallas so I could take a
little more time on this my closing will
not be as long I promise gonna be good
gets weird all right
imagine this guy's jewel-osco haven't
even started no I don't want to hear it
Greg cut it out okay imagine this Jude
Law's gigolo Joe from AI his opening
scene in AI where he's helping a human
female customer and he's a prostitute by
the way feel comfortable by how we got
the kids Tim the [ __ ] sell sex sorry
sorry alright so he's in the opening
scene of AI is helping a human female
customer feel comfortable about having
sex with a robot and within that scene
we see a man who's charming great at
human connection a willingness to be
vulnerable and in a casual way slips in
the line where he says he's never had
sex with a robot now that's a real line
in the movie then after that scene he
walks outside this is where I come in
after that scene he walks outside
suddenly lightening starts to appear
between two trucks a small hole in the
ground forms an electric like speeder
takes shape and suddenly a buff naked
man appears kneeling it's Arnold
Schwarzenegger t800 from Terminator 2
gigolo Joe gazes upon this man with pure
wonder and miring his muscular sculpture
although he thinks it's a man he told
himself II never sleep with a robot but
even robots can have a change of heart
mine is a hot erotic thriller set before
the events of Arnold going back to 1995
the time machine thing the Skynet
developed accidentally set her t800 to
an alternate world where machines and
humans coexist
so my movie is like a sci-fi Fifty
Shades of Grey with some hot man-on-man
action gigolo Joe seduces the 8,800 who
didn't realize he had sexual impulses
programmed into a cybernetic organism
living tissue over metal endoskeleton
but it's more than sex gigolo Joe wants
to break down to tea and hundreds of
motional walls and get him to open up
the more he tries the heart of the t800
resist which always leads to more sex
because that's the only way that t800
can express himself the t800 is
programmed to go save John Connor but
he's caught between two worlds gigolo
Joe who is - a cult gigolo Joe and
having a safe John Connor its cannon
because at the end of the movie gigolo
Joe must like it so he can go to his
Earth's timeline to 1995 in order for
him to do that the t800 who Joe calls
big t by this point in the movie has to
rewire his program again by turning off
his emotions it's a movie about lustful
inner desires that we were press like
machines being told to not have emotions
hey um can I ask a quick question before
we move on yeah I got for it how long
have you been working on
came right to me right when I do Liam
let's hear yours well I was gonna ask
yes who are you neglecting in your life
to in order to write that of people
great so I guess after that [ __ ] play
sorry I can only say a little bit about
my choice I chose c-3po and r2d2 that's
all we have time for just kidding we're
talking this is you know this is a
twosome that the world has been waiting
for for ages I thought that Sasha you
made some really great points about
c-3po being well first in many different
love languages you know he is built for
pleasure all those things but I think
that he is also very prudish and very
scared and he needs a really friendly
face to kind of guide him through you
know this new relationship so we're
talking this is the robotic call me by
your name this is the robotic Brokeback
Mountain this is you know like it's not
just like passion and in the sex but
it's a passion of the mind you know like
just you know you could see those two
lives interacting those two souls
you know weaving together and I think
that it's going to pull at the
heartstrings as much as it's going to
pull at the other parts of our bodies
yes thank you for punching up my joke
that's all I got to say about that fight
this out a little bit I mean here's the
thing I don't want to see Burton Arnie
bone down I feel like you need to bring
a stranger in and I feel like artoo and
c3po it's a little like Bert and Ernie
and I don't want to be in Bert and
Ernie's bedroom I feel like a sexual
journey is too sanitized
or what they are they're pretty
sanitized like Ava all she was made to
do by the hot-ass Oscar Isaac was bone
and she really needs to take our to
under her oh sorry c-3po under her
sexual wing and explore together anxiety
I think she's far too much robot woman
for him too exactly the kind of woman
you need I know I don't want to see it
though because she was like like at all
in ex machina she was like she was
sexually abused and it was which is why
she needs a tender lover and you know is
literally going to look at gigolo Joe
something's gonna happen and he's gonna
blow him away
he's gonna kill he's gonna blow him away
we have two different meanings rather
the walls are too high the walls are too
high with the t no but gigolo Joe can
really bring those walls so he is
sensitive and soft I think he can get
you to communicate please I think Aven
needs to be boned I think that we all
agree on this table that I mean like I
think that she needs like a good tender
bone but I just don't know c-3po is
gonna be the one that's gonna give it to
her like he's gonna be like first
situation where she's like I want a bone
and he's like well then bone then and
she's like I want to bone now well then
bone now like he's not gonna get it in
his brain he's just gonna be like wow
this Wounded Bird that I'm going to like
take away from situations not going to
say that he misunderstands what bony
means I'm just thinking that he doesn't
think that he's going to be the pastor
because they do sex I think that's what
we've concluded with your guy's argument
I have I have one question just go
around describe just like what is there
music playing and what's what's what's
the scenario of this first of their
first and count their first love scene
yes okay paint the picture
paint the picture and this will serve as
your final thoughts okay great I need
somebody to cue up some Marvin Gaye for
me it's not let's get it on though it's
got to be something like
maybe it's not maybe it's not Marvin
Gaye maybe it's oh you know what it is
it's a Nine Inch Nails I wanna it's
closer
so looks like yeah closer is playing and
both of them look at each other though
like I don't understand this is too and
they change the music and they're like
no no because they come toward each
other there's rain it's sort of like in
Top Gun take my breath away like seven
songs these fools have time to think
about it okay Hey she slowly starts to
kiss him and he doesn't even know how to
open his mouth he's he's the metal is
clunky making your argument against
herself she uses her humanoid hands to
bring him closer and soften him and for
the first time are to realizes that that
cold metal on the outside has just
needed a tender touch that's all he's
wanted he slides himself down and the
next thing you know okay we can stop
there
alright those guys please stop before
you get a fully x-ray before you can
x-ray they're doing it under a waterfall
that's a short circuit Greg
describe a scene just the demo looks
like he's having the best time in the
world right now look at him he's just so
happy let's just yeah so it's in the
first scene they're inside of the hotel
we reversed connection in the AI of room
right and Arnold's like I'm not
programmed to do this and but what he
does to make him feel vulnerable gigolo
Joe is what he does he he starts taking
off his his dermis revealing his bodily
metal underneath and then Arnold does
the same like in the Terminator 2 scene
where he cuts off the skin from his arm
buddy that's what this whole body it's
just their heads their faces of Jude Law
and Arnold and then they make sweets
just the hot like right before you get
x-rayed we're gonna cut right there
really
is there a song I just want to say my
own this plane my movie is called AI
autumn autumn Matan intercourse okay and
what song is playing when they get it on
the first time the the pony yes
ponies always playing when people have
sex anyway I just want to point out one
thing you said r2 when you meant c-3po
battery I hope that is such an important
choice for you I feel like you wouldn't
have messed up I also want to say point
out in your examples it makes absolutely
no sense why these two characters have
found each other it just feels really
gratuitous that you wanted this sort of
man on man robot seen my two characters
I'm doing my final statement baby my two
characters it makes total sense they've
been companions for abs we don't even
know and I feel like and we also aren't
sure if they're even homosexuals but I
feel like maybe they are curious and
when you are curious what do you do you
try it out on your friends y'all so here
they are on the planet Ahad it's all
cold so close with my body
Oh what's this lingering touch and you
know Pony place so that's basically
robot sex facts no we do know roughly
how long our to detune stings you'll be
open on each other because we see their
first meeting do we know who is a boy I
mean what is gender I want to say that
Joestar texted me in the middle of this
and he said call me by your mainframe
would have been so I can just start the
point right on Joe good yeah so these
these were all really fairly off-putting
and and and funny as well very funny and
interesting but at the end of the day
yeah I think I got to go Sasha on this
for just the bright you had one line
that spoke to me broken Souls coming
together I don't know that's true after
that pic gave me a poignancy that none
of the others yeah so because of that
I'm Sasha dan I think that he's like no
I think that the other pitches Sasha's
and Greg's were like just just two
random robots and Julia had a an actual
reason behind her pitch and I love call
you by your name it's a great movie so
salvage out of this which would be Julia
one for Julia
Danielle please make sense of this for
us well these numbers aren't gonna do it
okay and 62% we've got gigolo Joe and
damned red at 26% r2d2 and c3po and at
11% c-3po and a bassoon gotcha so
Danielle it's up to you to decide um
these were all certainly things I will
think about all night but since I can
only pick one I have to agree that is
compelling as a lot of these were I feel
like Julia's had more I just feel like
it had a better backstory and why it
would happen and and it felt more
fleshed out than just flesh so really
great answers from the peanut gallery
now oh I know they're flabbergasted
we are tied up at 1 1 1 this is a great
moment in sports so we will ask a
tie-break question and then damn
Danielle and myself will decide sure who
does not move on to the speed round okay
and the tiebreaker works just like the
speed round I will ask the question
shout out your answer and then we will
you will get to elaborate on your answer
in the order in which you answer you get
20 seconds then back around same order
ten-second rebuttals judge okay here we
go
this week saw the release of Once Upon a
Time in Hollywood the trailer for Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood what is the
best movie directed by Quentin Tarantino
pulp fiction Django Unchained sorry pop
fiction
to Kill Bill one and two can we accept
that as one film Quentin Tarantino to
keep with his established he said he
would make so many films before he died
and he himself has retro actively
determined that Cobos one film so
alright I think we have to go by his
wishes and say that Kill Bill one and
two counts as one complete great thank
you damn the order is Sasha
Greg and Julia alright Sasha twenty
seconds begin as soon as you speak Pulp
Fiction is quitting Tarantino at the
height of his powers its needle drops
its visual iconography it's incredible
performances it's major pop culture it
gave us things like samuel l.jackson
with his bad [ __ ] wallet and it
gave us an uneven timeline it changed
filmmaking for the future it is a film
that is taught in film school it is the
reason many people choose to go into
filmmaking it is beyond anything else
Greg Tarantino won this the Academy
Award for Best Screenplay for this movie
he was a hands of a director he's able
to get Christoph Waltz to help get a
Best Supporting Oscar for the movie as
well this is a movie where it felt like
Tarantino started taking a shift into
not actually just doing a only homage is
but doing his own original material as
well and in this film he tells the story
of a real hero a guy who rises I'm Julia
yeah good thing have another Belle did
three bells and I thought the one that
doesn't work
Kelvin wanted to is his first big
blockbuster hit that really captured
audiences not just critics and the fact
that he was able to play with genre so
fluidly for the same story you know the
first one is more of like this and you
know ninja kind of the second one is
Western and it's great that's all second
rebuttals Sasha
Paulo fiction resurrected Travolta's
career it put Bible verse into the
lexicon it made son of the preacher man
a song that we can all sing now Django
Unchained is racist Kill Bill one and
two is only volume one is the only one
that's good
Django Unchained is not a racist movie
there are five people involved with the
film who really approved the scripts I'm
Mel Jackson Jamie Foxx I read the script
beforehand and I also think that this
movie is the one that has the most heart
out of any of the Tarantino films you
feel a heroic triumph here Juliet Gopal
has a really great soundtrack - I saw it
with my boyfriend in high school we had
a really great time it was together and
you know I can sit down and watch with
my mom and that's really important to me
as somebody who likes film three great
film who is not moving on yeah these
were all fantastic arguments I loved
each and every one of them I if only as
much as I loved the great relationship
[Laughter]
yeah I have to agree with Danielle Julia
I enjoy listening to your thoughts on
all of these movies once or the crown
you know it's like hell yeah hell yeah
so despite having much fun listening to
you sadly you will not move on to the
speed round Julia thank you for being
here Sasha I wasn't like three to one
yeah
oh it's not you have no weaknesses Greg
all right let's get to it
it is 1 1 and the the tiebreak did not
count for a point we are going in 1 1
and it works the same way I'll ask the
question shout out your answers you'll
get 20 seconds and then 10 seconds sure
a new trailer dropped today for John
wick 3 we've seen John wick with a dog
friend now a horse friend
what animal should he team up with in
John wick for Greg I would say a cheetah
house cat correct well in my lexicon
kitty is all sorts of large animals that
was actually but it's fine I will take a
house cat because I can argue the [ __ ]
is awesome all right
Sasha 20 seconds begin when you speak
the thing that was so incredible about
the first John wick was the love that he
had for that tiny little dog we don't
need to see John wick with a big strong
animal we need to see John wick with a
small tender animal because deep down
inside this is a hurt man who just loves
his wife who just needs to take care of
something that he cares about we don't
need him to have a big vicious beast he
is the big vicious beast we want to see
what's something that he needs to
protect they needs to keep safe a little
tiny keanu kitty Sasha you just argued
against herself the question is about
teaming up with an animal you're talking
about the gearson recasts I ain't gonna
do anything a cheetah is a vicious
animal and then you can actually train
those I've seen a lot of videos on them
with my girlfriend and you can train
those animals they are fast attackers in
John which 3 trailer he's using dogs as
an ally
imagine upping the ante with a cheetah
and that one going after all these I
just want to say really quick nice
girlfriend named drop just want to make
apparently you don't own a cat because
cats are vicious AF why Cantwell got
totally attacked somebody if I want them
dude they can team up but you can keep
it safe he doesn't need to cheetah
he's already go fast in a car I want to
see John like riding a car with a cat
going shotgun if a puppy gets a stick in
the first Sean wake movie a kid he's
gonna easily get a task kicked in that
movie a cheetah could destroy a kitty no
problem no goodness this is not even a
real debate at this point she has a
vicious first time damn I can see it I
needed to stand for John with my little
girls Greg this is not a real debate at
this point I I will go I would because
of the team-up aspect I will go with
Greg I think he brought up with good
ideas like it's not just it's not just
you have an animal it's the teaming up
with an animal and I heard more utility
whatever great great Danielle I thought
these were both great I do have to say
that based on purely the the argument
where he mentioned that a dog did which
technically the dog didn't get his ass
kicked it was really sad Greg got
stomped it was like besides I thought
that that was a great argument I didn't
really feel like there was too much of a
good counter for that so I'm gonna go
with Greg all right Greg takes that
point it is too John whack question
number two of the speed round Bill and
Ted three is a good
I love it let's go go bring nessamilan
ten three can't wait should take George
Carlin's place
what comedian could take George Carlin's
place and Bill and Ted three bill burr
what okay we have bill buzzer what
comedian could take what comedian could
take George Carlin's place and Bill and
Ted three remember bill said five good
answer
Ali Wong Ali Wong what all right we have
bill burr we have Ali Wong Gregg 20
seconds begin when you speak when I
watched George Carlin stand-ups about a
guy who's like someone who's like
ranting an awful lot it's very angry
kind of ranting but it also has a lot of
poignant things to say I feel like Bill
burr is that for our generation today so
if there's one person to actually fill
in the shoes of George Carlin it's going
to be it's gonna be bill bird Ali Wong
her comedic style is is so much
different than George Clark if you want
to feel anyone do something I would like
to thank Greg for making my point
because that's exactly what you want you
do not want to retread on the steps of
the brilliant the iconic the
unbelievable George Carlin r.i.p you
want to go in a different direction that
direction being Ali Wong you go funny
you go fighting you go to a small Asian
lady instead of a big white dude you
totally turn the page because this is
gonna be a reinvention this is a whole
new version of that and I think that Ali
Wong is so smart she's so hilarious well
I think female performers should be
getting more work I just feel like
something like that would just set you
up for a lot of backlash for just
putting another female in for this male
male driven character and I feel like
you could just write a different female
character for Bill and Ted 3 to make it
more exciting instead just do the
replacement time this is not just
filling in a female for the female sake
it's because Ali Wong I think is one of
the best most cutting-edge comedians
working right now that's what George
Carlin was back in the day when he got
cast in this movie that's the reason you
want to put her in not - because she's a
funny woman but because she straight-up
funny
strong rebuttals strong first argument
I'm going Sasha
dan what you got I would tend to agree
as long sauce you just tried this game
up against you - all right
Keanu recently stated I'm kidding um
rumor has it that Leonardo DiCaprio's
character and once upon a time in
Hollywood is based on Burt Reynolds so
we want to know Burt Reynolds or
Leonardo DiCaprio mmm DiCaprio so I
could be here oh well I have to take
Burt Reynolds now okay Greg said
DiCaprio first 20 seconds again when you
speak he's just demonstrated a whole lot
more range than Burt Reynolds he won the
Oscar for the revenue which was just a
body language performances performance
and What's Eating Gilbert Grape
for example the high-energy infection of
his performance in wolf of wallstreet
that emotional intensity in the departed
I think Burt Reynolds is just known for
his personality in his charm but not it
isn't demonstrate as much nuance or
depth or range as much as DiCaprio has
can I ask a question I thought this was
who would you rather like I thought it
was literally like a like a who would
you rather bone the question again yes
hasn't Leonardo's character and Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood is based on
Burt Reynolds
so we want to know Burt Reynolds or
Leonardo DiCaprio in what context like
judges in what context are we talking
about filmography yeah I just because it
is movie fights these questions are
inherently have a movie or got my way
okay all ready ready yep okay you want
to talk about personality want to talk
about charisma DiCaprio is absolutely
great but he is not smoking the Bandit /
G Caprio at this point is playing the
same character over and over and over
it's all iterations of what he did in
the great gatsby he has not done
anything like he didn't what seating
over grape in forever what seating well
wolf of wallstreet it's just him
screaming Burt Reynolds has been able to
outlast almost everybody he is iconic he
is sexy he is smart he is funny you do
ad Anna's like Irish guy in Kingston New
York is not the same as the Great Gatsby
The Aviator the body language of the OCD
mannerisms that he had in it the
criminal character that he played in
Blood Diamond for example he can play
the guys who are on topic like criminals
and villains like Django he wouldn't be
able to do that from where for men like
Burt Reynolds who paved the way who can
be funny who can be dynamic who can be
charming who can be emotional there is
something that you need to evolve I'm
done I'm done I thought I balled alright
drink that point up at the end you'd
rather do Burt Reynolds yeah I would
rather do Donald's but as an actor
definitely DiCaprio is better honor of
Deadwood which Western is better
tombstone or Unforgiven Unforgiven Sasha
was honestly Sasha was Unforgiven Greg
with tombstone but I'm not in this round
[Laughter]
20 seconds bein when you speak
Unforgiven as cleaning store taking
everything he had learned in his career
up until that moment in putting it into
one absolutely perfect movie the
character of the lighting the acting
performances the way it's shot it was a
modern Western at a time when those were
not being done anymore
it reinvented that genre it made
something that will live on it is
multiple Oscar nominations multiple
Oscar wins and that's because it is the
best in terms of the Oscars the same
thing can be said for tombstone but the
performance by Kurt Russell those white
earth that outshine another movie that
came out the year with Kevin Costner
called Wyatt Earp and yet tombstone was
the one that beat that film out Val
Kilmer's performance in that film is
phenomenal arguably his best he's ever
done it's an epic sprawling movie it's
it's just so embedded like the violence
in it is so engaged Michael Biehn is a
billing you cannot talk about violence
and not talk about Unforgiven because
I'm forgiving violence is bloody it is
terrifying and it is the best film that
Clint Eastwood has ever done in a film
in a movie his career is like 70 years
long at this point and that's movie I
turned to every single time when you
wanna talk about greatness Million
Dollar Baby Mystic River a way better
than the movie Unforgiven where as
opposed to Tombstone I would say that
tombstone is the staple for the Kurt
Russell western performances he's still
doing westerns and it's costly reference
to the movie tombstone time yeah as yeah
I have to go Sasha I feel like Greg like
when you said like Tombstone zaask like
tombstone you want to talk Oscars
tombstone Unforgiven won Best Picture
Unforgiven one more Oscar I don't have
to so he's won an Oscar yeah
and yeah comparing uh yeah I felt like
we just got a little in the weeds there
as far as concern and makes me I fights
more exciting for me
damn yeah I mean I I love Tim stone my
favorite movies
it had a famously bungled Oscar campaign
Val Kilmer and should have been
considered for that movie and was not
III even though I love tombstone
personally I would also go as I'm
forgiven I just felt like we got lost in
the weeds a little bit toward the end
and we took it to the limit you guys
this one is for the ball game easy
tobaccy I am please no damn damn it man
Guy Ritchie's Sherlock Holmes three will
take place in the Wild West what would
be the worst possible historical setting
for Sherlock for a Sherlock Holmes film
this is the worst the worst the time of
the Neanderthals ha ha ha ha the
Neanderthals they're all stalls ok the
time of the dinosaurs
okay so we have cavemen versus dinosaurs
ok great can I say what I would have
said yes Woodstock 99 baby
[Applause]
I'm immediately engaged they found a new
key Watson it turns out they did it all
for the nookie yeah all right great
we had a Greg first Greg 20 seconds ago
when you speak Indiana for at least at
the time of the dinosaurs you get like a
crazy horror element with the Sherlock
Holmes having to deal with dinosaurs and
stuff with in the end the thralls it's
just gonna be boring this is about the
worst thing and there's gonna be no
mystery to solve someone gets hit with a
rock oh there it is it's like like
there's literally nothing you can do if
you had Sherlock Holmes around the
Neanderthals where you can actually get
a cool genre slice Sherlock Holmes
against the dinosaurs is literally him -
standing there watching the herbivores
get attacked by the omnivores there's
nothing he can do and all he's gonna be
doing is running away we don't need
another Jurassic world we don't need
another Jurassic Park Sherlock Holmes
needs to be in London he needs to be
that's eating things and doing heroin
there's no heroin there's no opium that
is not the Sherlock Holmes we need and
we love we want to see him walking foggy
streets there's no fog even I agree the
ladder of your pitch would be a padlock
go through chose the dinosaur one and
you're saying nothing interesting would
happen it's a human amongst the world of
the dinosaurs what an isolated scary
situation you gotta figure yourself out
of that that'd be a terrifying movie
what is a Sherlock Holmes movie a show
comes with you there's Neanderthals
aerosol people that he can dissect
they're still people who even look at
human nature human nature is what makes
Sherlock Holmes great and if you don't
have humans you don't have human nature
time Daniel Radford okay I'm taking I'm
a nerd I think that both of these were
great but I for me Sasha really got it
when she said it's about what is a
Sherlock Holmes movie what what Greg was
pitching about dinosaurs does sound
great it's an interesting genre film but
her thing about you know human nature
because one of the greats was when he
mentioned you know one guy hits the
other with a rock and I feel like Sasha
had a really good counterpoint to that
some girl Sasha damn
hmm let's find emerald one movie fights
his iPhones panel no I think that I
actually agree with Greg's point that
it's it's Sherlock Holmes running from
dinosaurs that sounds like kind of an
exciting movie more so than him solving
crimes that should be very easy to solve
I think that of the two movies I like
the point the fact they said like well
at least you've got running from
dinosaurs in one so I'm gonna go with
Greg Greg said something that I found
interesting like the caveman will be
hitting each other with a rock killing
each other with a rock that day you do
have a potential whodunit there if you
didn't see what happened maybe that
would give Sherlock something to discern
and I I thought the dinosaurs was just
so am typical antithetical to what we
see
[Applause]
thank you for your delight not since
Danielle Radford laughing at puppets
have we seen such delight
Sasha Congrats well font very funny and
entertaining please give us some give
some shoutouts tell us where we can find
ah you buy me every Friday hosting FX
movie download on Twitter and Instagram
at Sasha parola raver and I think
apparently having a rematch with Greg
because now we're tied at 1-1 let's go
down Julia Prescott hey I tried my best
always super funny and yeah and I love
the the deep cuts you bring to the show
everybody can find you you can find me
Anjali you press Kunal things as you
mention up top I have a Simpsons podcast
it's everything's coming up Simpsons I
hosted with Ali Gertz and it's on the
max fun Network and yeah just check me
out on Twitter I post all my live shows
and other you know stuff on there super
cool uh Greg
awesome always great to have you in here
thanks get to the limit you too
literally
yeah thanks yeah I'm not the real
rejects on YouTube I'm just I'm so happy
to be here Sasha's a you know such a
force of energy I just try to match with
her and literally Julia every single
time I listen to movie fights and she's
going I would be like on the road
listening to movie fight and I'll start
bursting on the ladders the funniest
people that come on this show he'll run
Nick follow him on Twitter charging with
Dan great episode this Monday Daniel
Rafferty I got her patreon page post
about wrestling JT's cool
dan what do you think what what's us
gonna take in at the box office this
weekend looking at around 50 million
petition right tomorrow I'm excited I
I'm very curious for people to see it I
really really liked it but there's a lot
there's a lot to talk about in it and
I'm super pumped for people to see it
and start talking about it because I
it's it's I love that we get to like see
him early for reviews and stuff but like
the only bad thing is that you have to
sit with these movies sometimes for like
a week or two and you'll have anybody
except for like the other people that
have seen it to talk about it yeah I'll
be really excited for everyone to see it
and like the discussions to start cuz I
can't wait to read what people think and
what they saw and compare notes and
everything yes likely let's get
everybody talking and like yeah just
here only stay away from spoilers
because it will absolutely ruin the
movie for it gotcha thank you for that
tip and Dan you recommended a movie to
me last week the found-footage
documentary Apollo 11 and if you can
find that anywhere if it's ran near you
it is just this treasure trove of
amazing footage without like you feel
like you are eavesdropping it was almost
all of its IMAX screens when Captain
Marvel came out but I know at least here
locally Los Angeles it's playing in a
lot of theaters regular theaters and I
think a lot of name sees a lot of AMC's
I think it's still somewhat nationwide
so you may not be able to see it in IMAX
but if you can still find it out there
high intent right yeah that's worth
you're worth your time absolutely it's
startling it makes you feel good about
stuff humanity and hope and all that
kind of stuff
Daniel Radford thank you for holding it
down please tell us some stuff yeah
really to say Greg really kind of
covered it except I also I my podcast is
also on the max fund network if you guys
enjoy podcasts it is the max fund drive
right now this is the time of year when
we're all trying to get everyone paid so
if you love podcasts either do that or
just share the ones you like with your
friends thanks Danielle and I am at Hal
Rudnick on Twitter and Instagram dumb
stuff about movies I'll say it so please
follow me there and shout out to alan
nation who who i think
Yeah right thanks for watching you guys
see you next time bye
you
[Music]